alex has become a mentor to many
a friend to me for sure and uh we're
gonna be unpacking his book 100 million
offers i do not have the hard copy
because we are in lockdown right now and
it is lost somewhere but it is right
there this book has been hugely
impactful for me and our community
in real ways
there's lots of stuff that you can dig
into in the internet marketing world
that's like exciting you know you watch
a keynote from russell brunson or any of
the greats and you're like freaking
pumped out of your mind you believe
you're one funnel away
but reading a book i was like [ __ ]
there's like so much good stuff in here
it feels like it it's gonna work and
then we applied it and lo and behold
uh it worked but but here's where i want
to start with you alex so our audience
high ticket entrepreneurs when i talk to
coaches and consultants about improving
their offer they typically think like no
i'm good like clients are getting great
results we just need more calls we need
better marketing
and so i want you to start by sharing
like what's the difference between an
offer and a coaching program
and then can you talk to us about why
you always want to start with the offer
i actually wrote the third book in the
second book first and i wrote this book
which is now the first book that came
out third uh and hopefully you tracked
what i just said
because i barely did um and the reason i
had to do that was with each book i
started with the third book and i was
like i actually kind of need this second
book to make sense which was lead
generation i was like well i finished
the second book and i was like you know
what if their offer is crap then that's
not going to matter anyway so i have to
start with the offer and so it kind of
went in reverse and it's because like as
i'm thinking through it i started
thinking about the things that i would
immediately want to look at in a
business but
usually there's these other weaknesses
that are much stronger and from a speed
to money standpoint changing someone's
offer is about the easiest thing that
you can do and a better business
intervention um and the offer touches so
many components of the business right so
it touches the lead generation component
so you get more people who are going to
respond than who otherwise would have
with a superior offer you get more
people to buy than who otherwise would
have you get higher pricing and more and
more profit as a result of a better
offer than you otherwise would and so
with each of those situations they
become multiplicative in their effects
on the business and when you put them
all together the offer is the lever on
all of them and so i could you know for
most businesses you could just turn the
entire business around by fixing this
one thing once that one thing is fixed
then you get into okay how much how many
different channels can we have access to
to generate leads you know the third
book is money model so how many
different ways can we can we monetize
the customer to increase our you know
our cash conversion cycle or basically
how quickly return a dollar so we can
spend more uh on the acquisition which
is the third book the reason we start
with the offer is because i think in the
marketing community at large and i say
that uh because just about here
everybody here is in the marketing
community at large um
this book i think was a hit at least i
perceive it as a hit
because it was the only book that i
think has talked about the product and
so no one talks about product in the
marketing community and so i think it
seems so far into many people but if you
look in the software world they only
talk about product and they don't care
at all about marketing uh because they
know and if you will allow me to expand
on this for a quick second and then we
can i'll get into the questions
i'm gonna i'll share something with you
that's been very very um impactful for
me so a lot of people look at jim launch
and they try and understand the success
behind the company and for context for
everyone here
the first year i was in business in gym
lunch uh at least once we switched the
licensing model we took home 17 million
dollars in profit
for perspective let me pause for a
second it was as [ __ ] insane for me
as it might sound to you
so it is not lost on me and we went from
3 million in profit the year before to
17. um and a lot of people looked at our
funnels they thought you know alex's
sales genie or it's it's it's our it's
our creative it's our hooks it's all
it's all these things and many people
try to copy them
but no one was able to duplicate the
numbers and success in the scale um
and it was because the product was
superior i mean i see mark was here i
know mark was one of our early clients
he had a gym i guess now he's doing high
ticket which is awesome the average
client made 30 000 in their first 30
days that was the average which means
half of people did better than that
and so if you look at the internet
marketing community at large i would i
would doubt that there are many offers
that produce that kind of result and so
we were able to get 36 to one return on
advertising and actually the first year
we got a hundred to one return on our
advertising um because honestly the
advertising wasn't the thing that was
doing the vast majority of the work it
was word of mouth it was referrals and
so people might see the ad but they had
heard about it in three or four other
places and i'm told that the book is
having a similar effect it's on people's
news feeds and things like that and for
context everyone here there's no book
funnel there's no upsells i've spent no
dollars on advertising and it sells a
thousand copies a day right now
with no advertising i got reached out to
people like hey man how are you how did
you achieve this organic
something with the
with the book and i was like we just
tried to write a really good book um and
i think that it's it's it's often
overlooked and so this is the piece that
i'll finish with and then we'll we can
we can rock in
but if you think about the six
acquisition channels that exist from
clients right you've got paid media
which is advertising of any kind you've
got owned media which is your list of
all your people you've got earned media
which is the platforms that'll
distribute your stuff organically like
we're on facebook right now so this is
an organic hones that's earned media
right and then you've got the three
people based which is you got manual
outbound uh you've got affiliates and
then you've got referrals and word
word-of-mouth
of those six that i just named
five of them are linear in nature what i
mean by that is that if i put a hundred
dollars in i get a set or fixed ratio
back so i put a hundred in i can get a
thousand out where i do a hundred calls
and i get x appointments right it's the
same if there's a fixed ratio and then
you just increase in scale right and
with most of those they're diminishing
in nature in terms of the more scale you
add the return ratio diminishes with
referrals word of mouth
it is quadratic
which means it's exponential and so it
is the hardest one to achieve but once
you achieve it it is the one that will
pay you so handsomely that is worth the
disproportionate investment of time and
the difference between a good book and a
great book is large this made a great
book an exceptional or remarkable book
or remark worthy as in it was so good
that you had to tell someone about it is
even harder right but that extra
uh the extra amount that extra increment
of return yields outsized returns in
terms of the practical use of that value
and so i think that for us so many
people just you know slap a bunch of
videos together and say this is my
course
uh rather than
having the in-depth or trench knowledge
to go from being good to great or going
from great to being exceptional
and i will tell you that having now
which is weird i
i feel like uh an older person in the
internet marketing space now which is
hilarious in terms of years uh in it
rather than age
the people who who continue uh to live
on
uh and not
fizzle and pop are the ones who have
superior product because usually the
people who do not uh wither from the
stress or the pressure of unhappy high
ticket clients
and so the only way you can weather that
emotionally unless you have no
conscience
is by having a superior product and
having intentions of truly always
improving the products so that you can
weather those storms because you and
only you can know your intentions i
think that would be at least my word to
this and my test with acquisition.com
which if you read in the book is kind of
the venture that that i've been focusing
on for the last year my goal with that
business
were really the portfolio of businesses
is to grow it exclusively off of inbound
because of the other five channels i've
grown each of those to multiply figures
in terms of how much i've been able to
generate from them but i have never done
um one off of kind of earned media and
purely inbound and so um that was the
goal and in order to do that we had to
make sure that the product was truly
exceptional and i can tell you that if
the people that make much more money
than me it seems to be a constant in
that it is a one-time investment to make
a superior product that has compounding
returns most of the wealthiest people
that i know try and invest in something
one-time that will pay them forever
whereas most of the poorest people i
know try and consistently have to do
things that they have to do over and
over and over and over again you have to
make new campaigns you have to make new
reach outs you have to make new phone
calls those are all things that you have
to do in order to keep going and as soon
as you stop them the business ends but
if the product is superior the product
will run on its own
and
coincidentally the profit is extremely
great because you have no cost of
acquisition
you touched on a couple things there and
obviously a big focus of what you see
this around superior product but i would
say um 100 agree but i would say also
people can't uh distinguish the fact
between the reality of the quality of a
product and deception in the market
right so can you talk a bit more about
how your product is both your offer and
it's not right it's not just about
adding two more coaching calls a week
it's not like i have my community on
facebook or some other platform can you
talk a bit more about like what that
looks like
with the offer it's kind of it it's kind
of this really interesting thing of the
it's the bridge between prospect and
client right and so it has components of
both sides it has components of
promotion embedded within it but it also
has components of product and so the
offer is really communicating
across the bridge what it's like to be a
client to a prospect and so we're
thinking about what are the problems
what are every single problem both known
and unknown and a little pro tip because
if you read the books how i do it uh pro
tip for everybody if you want to include
bonuses include one or two bonuses that
solve a problem that only occurs upon
success
so for example if i was taking on a
company for acquisition.com then a bonus
might be i'll also you know introduce
you to all my tax shelter people also
introduce you to my legal team also
introduced my investor people who will
help you um keep more of the money that
we're going to be making right so we're
going to solve a problem that's going to
assume success and so all of a sudden
your prospect is going to have a higher
belief in that they're going to achieve
it because why what other reason would
you be
solving problems uh that that assumed
success right unless people were being
successful to circle back to what you
were saying earlier dan the perception
right of the product um
has to be the thing that
appears valuable and your ability to do
that will also be predicated on the true
value of the product so it is it is both
ways right um but the idea is and i
think this might be contrary to some of
the things that are in the internet
marketing communities that i believe
that you should solve every prospect's
problem most things operate like a
pipeline and so if you have 100 steps if
you miss 99 it still won't work it's
like a car engine like is there a more
important part in the car engine than
another part well they're all required
so they are requisite pieces and i think
most times people solve one or two of
the things they might bring an engine uh
and they might bring gasoline but they
don't have wheels or they don't have
spokes or they might not even have the
nuts on the wheels right uh to keep them
on and so it's really thinking through
and i think that's where the the depth
of knowledge is so important where like
i tell this story and hopefully it'll
illustrate the point here i believe in
doing the really ugly unscalable stuff
first so that you can have the depth of
knowledge to to do the scalable thing a
lot of people want to jump the gun and
go straight to
i mean i can't tell you the amount of
times i've talked to quote agency owners
who are like
man these realtors can't make money on
my leads and i actually had a a an
agency that i worked with for almost a
year on our software platform
and every month i would just say why
don't you just get a real estate license
and actually work your leads
and finally he did it and in his first
month he made five times more money than
he did
three years prior because he actually
knew what the [ __ ] he was talking about
right and so gym launch became as big as
it was because i spent two years on the
road launching 33 different gyms in
different markets in person working the
front desk so we knew the nuances and
the differences of what time of day to
call and what cadence then what text to
use in this type of market what types
using this type of market and we were
able to troubleshoot those things so
easily and successfully that our client
saw a disproportionate amount of success
and then in the sales call
and when in creating the offer we could
say hey if you're if you're familiar
with orange clapham talks about a flash
troll right which is where you talk
about all these little features and
problems that they haven't even
encountered yet that you have already
solved and then in so doing you
demonstrate such superior expertise to
the person that they immediately trust
you as an authority and then all of a
sudden the remainder of the conversation
is very easy because they know that they
don't even have the perspective from
which to make a judgment they transfer
that that authority over to you to make
a judgment on their behalf so i want you
to kind of go deeper on something you
just said because uh
tied to that i've heard you talk about
this a lot which is that people try and
solve problems that don't exist when it
comes to the scalability of their offer
if they're scared to offer too much and
they have zero clients or a few clients
they go i just don't know how this is
going to look at 50. and so can you talk
about the kind of those spectrums of
like easy to sell hard to sell easy to
deliver hard to deliver
so i think that
most entrepreneurs would be best served
especially in the beginning and so it's
hard to make broad sweeping statements
because there's always exceptions to
them but by and large most entrepreneurs
who are probably in this community
selling high ticket coaching services
would be best served selling a less
scalable offer at higher ticket first
and then piece by piece removing pieces
that are less scalable and so you do
that because you give higher touch to
clients you have more more profit in
your acquisition because most done for
you models for example uh if done
properly i'm not saying agency models
because i'm not a big fan of agency
models but um most done free models if
done properly should yield excess cash
and the issue becomes operational
fulfillment right which is how i prefer
to have my bottleneck in the operations
and scale than in demand generation that
is just my preference some people prefer
different ways i prefer it that way um
and so the easier something is to sell
in general which is going to require
more handholding in your part more
services more things the easier it is to
sell right on the flip side if you just
sell a course via webinar it becomes
very very difficult to sell in general
you have to have very very high
persuasive abilities in order to sell
that and a pretty unique opportunity
right if you're telling how to make how
to run facebook ads i think that time
has somewhat come and gone right and so
uh the idea is i would prefer to be on
the easier to sell part of the spectrum
gain the experience generate the cash
flow and then use the cash for to solve
future problems of scale
um and i think that that is a better
sequence that has a higher likelihood of
success for most people
yeah and i would say there's a huge
assumption baked into that which comes
down to a really wildly uncommon opinion
you have which is on pricing
because all of that assumes that you're
going to have then excess cash and
enough to deliver and that it's priced
right so can you talk a bit more about
pricing because i think for most people
we do what dan kennedy calls the wag
pricing model which is just the wild ass
guess or the industry norm right where
you just go like what does this person
do what does this person do great i'll
be somewhere in the middle or a little
bit cheaper so when we got into that you
know in our first coaching business um
which was obviously gym launch we uh the
highest priced person at the time was 5k
uh the lowest price people were kind of
agencies doing 500 bucks a month so that
was kind of the range of the marketplace
and so when we came in our front-end
program was 16k our back-end program was
actually a three-year 126k program so
the pricing was so vastly different than
everyone else that it caused the
prospects to take pause and say there
must be something different going on
here paul is there and then if you think
about what a lot of people are seeing
with the book or at least i'm told is
that the book's kind of all over a lot
of people's news feeds imagine you have
this kind of pricing
with all of this word of mouth that's
surrounding it and then it creates this
allure
right and so the idea is that we have to
charge so much in order to get the
clients and prospects more invested
because a in a very real way price
confers value right so there's a story
on the book but it's it's it's basically
if you had three people thread try three
different wines the high price the
middle price and the low price and then
rate them most people rate the highest
price wine the best but the thing is is
that when they do these studies they
actually make all three wines the same
and so in a very real way price does
confer value your product that's number
one number two is that if you change the
quality or increase the quality of your
prospects
you will increase the quality of your
products so what i mean by that is if i
am working with uh somebody who's making
five million dollars a year right and
then i give them a book right dan
all of a sudden that book to dan is
worth two million dollars this year
right if i give that to somebody who's
never started a business before the book
might be worth some inspiration and so
there's a very real difference in the
value that my product delivered based on
the quality of my prospect independent
of the change in my product
and so the second point is that if you
change and increase the quality of your
prospects you can also charge your
concurrently higher price based on the
value that is true that you were
delivering to that person the third
piece is that i like having pricing
power in general because there is a
strong strategic advantage to being
higher priced i just named two of them
right
in the marketplace but one of the
biggest ones is that you have so much
more gross profits left over that a you
can spend more on the acquisition but b
you can do things that other people
can't and so you further eliminate or or
separate yourself from the competition
by being able to provide things that no
one else can right so for example in the
gym launch world because we had a lot of
clients that are we still continue to
have a lot of clients that are in the
same markets we were able to spend 50
000 a month every month on testing
advertisements and then we would just
license those ads out to all of the
facilities across right no one else
could do that because i had the spare
cash that i could just put into
marketing and then only hand scratch off
lottery winners to them that they could
just go and cash in right because they
already knew they worked and so i could
hire a team just to build all this stuff
for them and there weren't even
franchisors at that time that we were
doing that stuff and honestly they still
don't and so we're able to still run a
very high growth profit on even that
product line and so the idea is like how
can i do things that no one else can do
and the thing is is i would start with
the price first now obviously it has to
be based in reality in terms of the
value you can provide but a lot of times
with the access gross profit you can in
a very real way provide more value and
so that's why in the book i like to
anchor the pricing in the beginning
because that just kind of sets the stage
but then when we get into the value
creation side of it it's like how can i
how can i make it so likely that they
are successful how can i get them to be
successful in half the time and how can
i do it so i can eliminate effort and
sacrifice and for those who don't know
the difference between effort and
sacrifice effort is what someone has to
do that they don't want to do that they
weren't doing before they started
working with you sacrifice is when they
have to stop doing something that they
enjoy doing that they were doing before
they started working with you that they
can no longer do and so the idea is how
can i limit eliminate the effort and
sacrifice cut the time in half and then
increase the perceived likelihood that
they're going to achieve the result that
they want and so that was kind of the
basis i mean in general if there was one
summary picture for the book in terms of
how to create value it's the value
equation and so the remainder of the
book is basically the executions the
tactics around how do we actually do
this how do we create a dream outcome
that's appealing to the person right
making a million dollars for most men is
more appealing than being more handsome
not saying that they don't want both but
they probably want one more and in a
real way a lot of guys would spend five
hundred thousand dollars to make a
million dollars but probably wouldn't
spend five hundred thousand dollars to
be more handsome or maybe they would but
it depends on their income right
perceived likely of achievement i'll
give you an example here so if if you
guys were if you had your if for i see a
lot of guys on here but if your wife
were getting uh plastic surgery or
you're getting plastic surgery whatever
right you have two surgeons that have
the exact same they're gonna do the
exact same surgery on you right the
outcome's the same now so i'm i'm
controlling for the outcome and showing
you different pieces of the value
equation if one of them was about to do
their first surgery ever out of medical
school and the other one was on their 10
000th surgery
in their career
which of them would you rather work with
this one which one would you rather pay
more this one you probably asked this
guy to pay you because you were his
first surgery right and so in a very
real way the perceived likelihood of its
achievement increases the value
independent of the actual service being
delivered and so that is why it's the
second thing now most marketers focus
all their attention on the top side of
the equation this is what i did for the
first few years of my career when i was
at my gyms when i sold weight loss and
then even in the beginning of gym launch
it was all about how much money are you
going to make and then [ __ ] loads of
testimonials how much money you're going
to make [ __ ] loads of testimonials but
there are other ways to increase
perceived likelihood of achievement
which is kind of goes back to that flash
role argument i was saying earlier which
is here are all the things that you
didn't even think about that i have
already handled uh on your journey that
you didn't even foresee which then shows
my expertise that i know what i'm doing
and so the goal is to increase these as
much as possible
now the second half of the equation are
the detractors in a very real way in my
opinion the bottom side of the equation
is actually more powerful in persuasion
than the top side and the reason is
because it's very easy to make claims
it's very easy to talk about the dream
outcome right but it's much more
difficult
to actually decrease the time delay
which why for us one of the major kpis
we've always had as a company is how
much cash someone generates in the first
14 days working with us
right and so for us we drive towards
that equation and for us right now for
example the average cash collected in
the first 14 days is 15 500 right for
our client that is the average right and
so with that i can have a big outcome in
the first you know 14 days so they have
a very short time delay between when
they when they buy something and they
begin to start experiencing the results
right and so i'll give you a simple way
of providing value look at what everyone
else is doing in the market and do it in
half the time
right if all of a sudden for example as
an extreme version of this
i would say hey i'm selling a weight
loss product i use weight loss because
everyone understands it all right and as
soon as you click this you look at you
you pull your shirt up and you have a
six-pack right you buy my six-pack
program you click purchase and you have
a six-pack immediately how valuable
would that product be
extraordinarily
right
and so the idea is we made the product
more valuable not by changing the
outcome not by changing the perceived
like of achievement
but by simply changing the time in which
it took to achieve the outcome that was
promised and so as a marketing example
for example if i had a a marketing
agency again which i'm not a huge fan of
but if you had a marketing agency that
was commoditized service based right if
i were trying to provide more value i
would say as soon as as soon as the
contract is signed
if the prospect's phone rang
figuratively or their inbox you know was
filled and they got a book call
immediately with a qualified prospect
that was booked 30 minutes after they
got off the phone with you
how much more valuable would that be
than somebody that says hey it's gonna
take 30 days to ramp up it'll take
another 30 days to start seeing results
so it's like 30 days after that for you
to recoup and break even and then by
month six but like you have i've already
lost you right so much less valuable and
so the idea is the time delay component
is a massive area of value and if you
look at the biggest companies in the
world they look at time as one of the
major drivers of value time is thing
that most people value more than
anything uber came in because it was
more convenient right netflix came in
because it was more convenient than
doing the other things right which also
ties into the second part of the bottom
equation which is effort and sacrifice
right and so
the idea is again if i like weight loss
again i'll just use the example
we we asked susie right to give up
waking up you know sleeping in right
because she's got to wake up early to go
to the gym right now she's sore every
day so now she's got she's got effort
and sacrifice that are associated she
can't eat any of the foods that she
likes anymore she's got to eat separate
from her family her kids are making fun
of her she goes out she misses her she
can't drink champagne at her at her
sister's wedding on top of that all like
everything that she loves about life is
gone right and and here's the best part
it's gonna take her 12 months to maybe
look a little better but still not be at
her goal so no wonder it's so [ __ ]
hard to sell and so the idea is how can
we eliminate as many of these barriers
as possible in the effort and sacrifice
component so that we can make it as
instant and as fast for them and the
reason i made it a fraction is because
in theory if you can get the bottom side
of the equation to zero as in it's
instant and there's no effort in the
sacrifice then you have an infinitely
valuable product right and if you think
about like what amazon's doing
right they're getting so close to
literally you just like click one button
on your phone or maybe it's i mean very
soon it'll just be you talk out loud
your phone will hear you through a lexus
alexa
and then a drone drops it off at your at
your house two hours later
they are shrinking that gap the effort
and sacrifice and the time delay so much
that the value becomes so infinite
infinite and that's why they're becoming
such a behemoth right and so when i
think about products and how do we
create value because a lot of people
throw the term out right they're like
god they've got to give value got to
create value if you're like what is
value
like and so this is my best attempt at
at writing down or at least
compartmentalizing what i believe value
to be in an equation so you can look at
your own products and say how do we
measure up here and perceive likelihood
how do we measure pure effort and
sacrifice how can we make things happen
faster for them is there a dream outcome
that we can communicate in a way that's
more compelling or more relatable i'll
give you a hack so one of the things
that we did on our onboarding process
that we switched was um so our so our
sales team takes no string sales calls
and they close the sale and they
transfer over to the onboarding team and
so for a very long time it was just hey
so it says seems here that your goal is
you're trying to make an extra ten
thousand dollars a month awesome that's
gonna help you do cool and so they were
already impressed because we actually
read the notes that were from their
sales call mind blowing right but it
increased their perceived likelihood of
achievement because they're like oh
these people are buttoned up right crazy
by the way to have a handoff between
sales and the first which they talk to
after they give you money anyways what
we started doing was we started asking
them on the sales calls of course what
is that like why is that why is ten
thousand dollars the number why is that
meaningful for you why not why not
twenty eight thousand why not five
thousand right like was there is there
something as a result of having ten
thousand dollars that is going to change
in your life in one way or another
because if there weren't there would
there'd be no point in even making the
money and so then they tell you the real
reason which is uh you know we've got
two kids and i really wish my wife could
be at home with them whatever right and
so what we do in the onboarding call is
now we can tie more accurately hey so it
shows here that what you're trying to do
is trying to retire your wife all right
so that's what we're going to try and
help you do here with the program and
what i need you to do in order to do
that is you got to follow these steps so
now all of a sudden we got way higher
buy-in way higher compliance and we
actually had higher conversions on the
back end simply by changing the
on-boarding process and not even
changing the product you could make the
argument change the auditing process is
a part of the product but hopefully you
understand my point so if you can more
accurately depict the dream outcome to
your prospect they will value it in a
better way it'll also increase the
perceived likelihood
that's super good man and i i want to
get your thoughts on something that i
know that a good portion of the 130
people with us right now are probably
thinking which is that they need to
upgrade their market
oh i want to charge more money so i'm
going to go find the people that have
more money and i can't tell you how
often people like you know what are you
qualifying for and say the dm's to get
someone into a call they're like oh
they've got to be making six figures i'm
like why and they're like because they
you know it's easier for them to pay for
my program whatever it might be can you
talk really quickly about
niche slapping
which is a big thing for us in the
coaching space and then also the
economics behind your pricing of gym
launch and how much money the average
gym owner makes yeah so those are a
couple of things so i'll start in
reverse order of what i remember from
the question so uh so the average gym
owner makes uh 29.50 a month of
take-home income on about a 300 000 a
year uh
uh business right brick and mortar and
so you're talking about 36 thousand
dollars a year roughly um in take-home
income it depends on the source of the
data but it's around 30 to 36.
and so our program was 16 000 up front
right um and then the back-end program
was 42 000 which is literally more than
someone makes in a year
and so
the the idea so i'm not against you
finding higher quality prospects if you
can make your product so good that it
will pay for itself immediately then
that is where you really unlock
basically unlimited money right if you
can help people actually make the money
to pay for your program rather than
asking them to pay for the program and
then get the result
you you're tapping into like the
universe right you don't you know
there's no there's no limit on the
amount of money that you can make and
the reason that we were able to make so
much is because we made so many people
so much money like that's the real like
there's no other secret to that like we
made a lot of people a lot of money and
as a result of that they were happy to
pay us for the money that we were making
them most people couldn't afford i would
say 50 of the gyms that we sign up can't
afford the next month's payment if we
don't make the money so we have to make
the money which is why most gym
competitors have entered the space have
never been able to get to a tenth of our
size right it's because they they
weren't able to operationalize the value
the way we were able to so that's that's
in terms of like the the value compared
to the price in terms of the income of
the person in terms of niche slapping
the simplest answer i can give you might
be might be a story so i was talking to
again agency owner but i guess we live
in the marketing world right different
different agencies this is
an agency coach all right so he coaches
agencies he's like hey i'm getting all
these dms about doing general business
um do you think i should go into general
business and i said i think that's a
terrible idea there's a couple reasons
one because i didn't think he had earned
it yet um but second and probably more
importantly the question is i was like
have you reached the market cap the
answer is no of course not doing 5
million a year in an industry that does
20 billion or 50 billion whatever it is
in the entire marketing agency space
he's probably not pretty close right so
he had risen to his level of
incompetence and so it didn't really
matter him switching the niche that he
was going to he was just going to rise
up to his next level of incompetence
which is going to be the same as what it
is now but more realistically he would
drop to two and a half on here raised to
two and a half on here now be ceo of two
businesses which you can only have
like think about this how many publicly
traded companies have a ceo that is
being ceo of home depot and ceo of
coca-cola he's like well
i'm doing both right i'm running two
companies because i'm gonna figure out
which one explodes it's [ __ ] stupid
right it's [ __ ] and yeah we do it
all the time as entrepreneurs and so you
have to pick and then you have to commit
and then the hardships that you
experience are the things that you have
to perceive or at least for me that i
perceive as barriers that no one else
will go through there is that when i
encounter them once i solve them someone
else who comes behind me will encounter
them and not know how to solve them and
the more of these rungs that i pass the
more difficult it is for someone to
achieve the same thing and so
at
any of the markets but i tend to ask
when people come to me
i see what like let's say somebody's
making five billion dollars a year i
would just ask them because they're like
hey man i'm thinking about switching
about switching markets and i'm like
well why they're like well i want to
make more money i'm like cool i'm like
well why don't you just
double your business
and still have one business and then
inevitably with enough questions it's
the answer becomes because i just don't
know how right it's like well then let's
solve that problem
and then grow the business rather than
just
feed our egos and have a quick win
because you have a couple dms of people
who say they want general business
coaching which will then inevitably
flounder once you get into the real
space against dudes who make way more
money than you are much better at
business and so like the reason you
niche down is because you don't want to
you don't want to fight against bigger
competitors there is a time to become
tony robbins right but most people
aren't there and so it's much better to
cater your marketing and your messaging
and your product to an individual and in
so doing provide outsized returns and
value which you can then capitalize on
right if i had a generic facebook ads
program five years ago i might have made
a few million dollars but because i was
able to say hey i'm gonna copy and paste
this here's every [ __ ] step of this
process to turn eyeballs into gold
immediately because i didn't have to
tailor it right everything out of the
box was exactly the way it needed to be
for that prospect right so nothing else
needed to change whereas
the more wiggle you have in your product
because it's individualized and variable
between markets and avatars and things
like that then all of a sudden your your
value drops because you can provide
because you're providing less of it in a
very real way because otherwise every
single one of the clients should have a
personally catered uh program but you
can't do that because you're not
committing to a niche yeah chris just
said there's so much to unpack here
hurts um
there was someone here i know that's uh
being in our pipeline for all 50 years
old uh runs a real estate coaching
company he's just like this live is
changing my life so
when we're talking about an offer i
think most everyone gets
how this impacts the very end of their
sales and marketing process in that
short time at the end of a call where we
go i think i can help would you like me
to share a bit more about what that
would look like right and and that's
what we think that you're telling us to
do is create something that makes that
part really easy and of course having a
great offer makes that part easier how
do you feel like we should be thinking
about and utilizing a grand slam offer
to improve our marketing is it simply
talking more about what it is that we do
how do you think about that i think each
of the bonuses that i was talking about
kind of that flash roll of all of the
all the problems that your prospect
doesn't perceive yet like that in my
opinion b2b advertising is all about
demonstrating expertise in advance when
you're creating a grand slam offer you
have so many problems that are being
solved that you can speak to them and
ideally i would like to speak to them in
a way that i know my competition is not
solving them and so by doing that i'm
strengthening myself and at the same
time throwing rocks against my
competitors because i know that i'm
solving problems that they aren't and
i'm doing that because i've actually
done it and they have not and they're
making it up because they're looking
because they bought a course and how to
be a guru and they never actually did
[ __ ] right and so and many of your
competitors are the same way of course
not you because you're listening to this
and that's not you of course but other
people
other people your competitors right are
like that right and so the way to to get
around that and be able to use the offer
is again and have the in-depth knowledge
of every single problem that's going to
happen and then your marketing takes on
its own unique language because everyone
else tries to talk in features and
benefits and promises and you can think
this is what it means but when you can
talk about the problems in a very
specific way because you've experienced
them because you went through it because
you know that suzie's always going to
[ __ ] complain about the music in the
gym the bathrooms aren't clean enough
mark might get a laugh out of that only
a gym owner would know that but a
marketer who's never been a gym owner
wouldn't know that right [ __ ] susie
right exactly the point is is that if
you know the pains then in your
marketing my offer is going to have
components right so i might cover some
of those aspects that i know are nuanced
pains and solve problems that no one
else is solving because i'm talking
about something else was talking about
because i actually did it and i'm saying
i is all of us not
not me specifically tell us about
your marketing plan right now and what
we can learn from it because you're
giving away all this stuff for free
and i think there is this huge lie in
our industry which is we we should keep
our marketing like we
hear like nifty things like we we show
our know-how but give know how right and
so it's like oh we demonstrate we know
we're talking about but we actually help
no one and hopefully they're you know
agitated enough they jump on a call and
you're kind of taking this very
different approach and
in my experience with gym launch
marketing it's always been different
you've actually provided a stack of
value up front so much so that probably
makes competitors who provide that same
stuff or similar for paid
in their program pretty scared so so
coach us on that for a second we all do
marketing whether it's organic or paid
how should we be thinking about
demonstrating value and giving stuff
away can we hold on there because i want
to add one thing to the last question
that i think would be a really good
thought
so from the offer perspective to effect
marketing i want to give an extreme
example because it came to me as you
were saying that
if you said i will get you this outcome
for free guaranteed or pay you twice as
much as you paid me how difficult do you
think it will be to acquire customers
not hard it wouldn't be hard right at
all and so what ended up happening would
be the bottleneck would become your
operational your operations right
isn't that so much better of a problem
because then you have flow that you can
then consistently test things on and fix
the operations right as you [ __ ] up
which you inevitably will in the
beginning and then you eventually get it
right and the other piece of that is
that's an extreme example of like
it's free i'll get to this crazy outcome
and if you don't i'll pay you twice as
much and if you're like alex that's
insane what do you think i did for two
years flying out to gyms for no cost to
them i literally sat at their front desk
for three and a half weeks
in the middle of nowhere
spent my own money on advertising paid
for my own hotel my own flights made the
calls made the sales myself did the
onboarding and introduction of the
nutrition plans where i would sell them
supplements and i did all of that and
that you know how to do anything
so if you're like this guy's saying
something that's totally unreasonable i
did it for two years
and so like
i say that because i really do believe
in this right and so if you the idea is
how can i give away a crazy offer that
no one would say no to and think how can
i get no one to say no to this right and
if you're afraid of it that's okay
that's fear you know
i'll just i'll leave it at that anyways
and so if you want to right if you want
if you want to [ __ ] out a little bit
you can just take one step back and say
okay well everyone would say yes to this
maybe 90 of people say yes to this and
this is something that i'm willing to do
okay cool right and so the idea is how
how few of these pieces can i peel back
versus the other extreme which is hey
buy my thing maybe you get results maybe
you don't i don't care i got paid either
way it's your fault which is for the
most part most coaching offers
think about that right and if you're
like man i'm not confident enough that
we're going to be able to deliver on
those promises then fix the [ __ ]
product
right and stop selling the [ __ ] you're
selling well it's like the why are you
selling it to begin with
if you can't have the strong offer and
the strong guarantee behind it then the
product sucks then you're never going to
make a ton of money because the product
sucks and you're never going to be able
to market it and here's a mind [ __ ] for
you all right so i told you that you
have a compound there's six channels
right and one of them compounds and is
quadratic
the reason the other reason sony the
people end up fizzling and popping when
they become gurus is because the word of
mouth marketing that is working against
them
outpaces them they sold enough people
and enough people told enough people
about how much their [ __ ] sucked that no
one responds to their ads anymore
because you either have a positive
quadratic
force behind you that is just feeding
you every day where you have a negative
quadratic force behind you but the word
of mouth is always happening it's just
whether you're controlling it or not or
whether you know about it or not and so
anyways i just wanted to touch on that
based on the last question but the
question that you just asked
just repeat it real quick just for
everybody on here well i just want to
touch on something you just said which
is this solves the age old challenge uh
that people are especially experiencing
now which is the coaching industry is
more saturated than it's ever been right
and there are 101 people that are
promising the same thing that have the
same deliverables in their program more
or less and you're now trying to figure
out how to stand out of the marketplace
and the answer is like be bitter like
that's really what i'm hearing you say
it's not like we're not trying to be
better wordsmiths or write greater copy
it's like actually create a product
that's superior so marketing is about
different businesses about better so
everyone talks about blue ocean but you
don't need to be blue ocean in the
product the product just needs to be
better and so many times the incremental
improvements over time do add up and
they do create outsized returns it's
just hard because it's boring no one's
like oh man we should improve our own
boarding process that's boring that's
not sexy you do a hundred of those and
all of a sudden a vast majority of your
clients are getting results right and
then all of a sudden they're like no
this program is awesome when someone
hears about it they tell their friends
and then that friend might not
immediately sign up but they might go by
your book they might go join your group
right or they might actually now respond
to the ad that they've seen 10 times and
be like well i did hear something about
dan so maybe i will check it out so in
my opinion i think the word of mouth
actually becomes the first tip of the
dynamo domino
and the paid ads actually kind of
function as as retargeting
even if it's cold you just don't know
that they have now been they've now
touched your brand in some way
and once they've had one word of mouth
or two word of mouth
now they will respond to the ad that is
called traffic and as far as hiros or
whatever it is you know whatever you're
tracking is right in your in that thing
it looks like it's new but it's not they
already got touched in other ways and
then walked in so i think much more in
terms of differentiating yourself in the
marketplaces you have to have a parallel
marketing campaign that is going on on
your behalf behind the scenes and um one
of the questions that i think is very
haunting but i think is very powerful is
right now if i if i were the god of of
marketing right thor god of marketing
right and i said right now
you can get no more customers from any
any any acquisition methods you're using
all right so you can't do you can't do
affiliates you can't do paid ads you
can't do reach outs you can't do any of
that stuff all right
the only way you can get new customers
is if your existing customers bring you
more customers
how different would the experience you
have with your customers look if that
was the only way you could get new
clients
and if you can think right now how
different it would look how much
interaction you would have how much
support would be there how you'd make
sure everyone was successful
then change that now
and then they will come
so going back to that question of giving
away too much
and this temptation to be really shallow
in our marketing and it kind of flicks
our expert muscles but not enough to
actually help people
you take a very different approach coach
us on that um it's kind of like the
the age old like
what happens if i train an employee and
then they leave
it's like what happens if you never
train them and they stay
right
and so it just faces the inevitability
that you're like you got to train all
your employees right or you got to
invest in all your employees and i think
you can use the same kind of thought
process which is
well 99 of people what if i give them
all this value and they don't buy
right well it's like what if you give
them no value right
and all they consume is your fluff and
so it's been my opinion that 99 of the
marketplace will never buy from it and
so there's the there's the human side of
it and then there's the money side so
first just touching on the human side of
it i sleep better at night knowing or at
least believing that
more people benefit from the stuff that
we give out right i feel like that's a
net positive just in general right so
that and i think most entrepreneurs i
talk to they say hey i want to make an
impact i want to help people to the
degree which that's true i don't know
but whatever it sounds nice and so i
think that if that is true for you then
why not give away more um in a recent
goal for myself as a total tangent but
i'm going to go for it anyways is to is
to die the man who gave them most um and
that's i maybe i'll never achieve that
but it's a nice goal for me
um on the money side
a couple things one is
if you give enough you don't have to ask
so you've heard of the jab jab jab right
hook thing right
let me tell you real [ __ ] secret
you can just jab jab jab and never ride
hook and people will just lay down
and say you win
the amount of dms i get a day
that offer me between 50 and 250 000 for
a day or an hour per day
is staggering
that's not an offer i have that's
nothing and i don't sell it
right but because there's been enough
value that they believe
has been i've there's a threshold that
has been met or surpassed and they're
like and most people have reciprocity
most people are normal people and if
they receive something they want to give
something back and the idea behind
marketing in my opinion is to trigger
that in people
is how can it give them so much that
they would feel unreasonable or guilty
to not pay me and i can't tell you the
amount of times where i had somebody who
read the gym launch book which is the
first book i wrote a few years ago for
the gym industry and uh they read the
book and they're like dude your book
tripled my business i i'm here a year
later and um i just i had to you know i
had to see what he's like you could do
nothing and i would just be happy to
sign up right and i think that in terms
of the fear of giving stuff away it's
pure scarcity and i'll define that
because i think scarcity and abundance
are thrown around a lot in the marketing
community but no one actually like
defines it kind of like value
and so my definition of abundance
is or being abundant
is
being someone who cannot be controlled
because they need nothing and so if i
don't need anything you cannot
incentivize me and therefore i cannot be
controlled which means i'm purely
autonomous which means i don't need to
give you anything to get something back
because i don't need what you have and
so i think what ends up happening when
you do this very valued value-centric or
value first approach is that you
inevitably end up playing the long game
and as a further tangent which hopefully
then will let me expound upon i think
that one of the most undertalked about
concepts in the marketplace is goodwill
and i think that goodwill compounds and
i think it compounds fast food than
revenue you can get outsized returns on
providing value into a pool of a
marketplace and that goodwill will
multiply
far faster than your asking will and if
you can hold off long enough
you won't ever need to ask
you can just keep giving and so the idea
of like when am i giving enough
is chilly
like give everything you have
and the reality is that most of the
stuff you have
and i'm saying this not as a pejorative
statement i'm saying this is in general
most of stuff you have might not be that
good
and what it will do is it will force you
to get better
and if there's ever been like a single
consolidated statement of like what alex
believes about making money it's people
just need to be much better than they
are
and most people suck at most things they
do especially the things they think
they're good at
a lot of you probably would think your
competitors are not that good
your competitors don't think you're that
good
and so the question is how can we how
can we make it so it's so unreasonable
for them to like i used to and this used
to be in part of my marketing i was like
people might say that they don't like
our methods i was like but no one's ever
said jim doesn't make people money what
are the biggest mistakes or i would say
what is your advice to us
to get to
for everyone under a million in revenue
to get to a million in revenue from like
high-level business principles and then
and this is the this is the key part
that you were 100 qualified to answer on
get to a million and take home
pretty much until about three million
per year in revenue um the advice pretty
much holds which is one product one
avatar on one channel and here's what's
hilarious i'll bet you there's a bunch
of people on here who have more than one
thing going on and they're probably also
selling more than one product they're
also selling to more than one avatar
let's think about this if you could only
pick one avatar to sell to and one
product to sell them in only one way or
one channel to access them
how much easier would your life pay how
much more quantifiable and simple would
that feel does anyone here even thinking
about quitting all the side hustles that
they're talking about or the half
project that they think might become
something i'm doing these two kind of
businesses i'll see which one works out
the answer is either of them will work
out but neither of them with an n
neither of them will work if you try to
do both and so the issue is not even
time
the issue is detention you only have so
much attention you only have so much
juju right there's only so much heat uh
and you have too many pans on the heat's
not concentrated enough and so you got
to put the juju on one problem because
believe it or not the guy who's crushing
you that's what he's doing
and so you're trying to compete with two
hands tied behind your back against
people who are putting every single
ounce of their life into just solving
one problem if you do that life gets a
lot easier and for me i would rather
make business easier than harder and so
that's kind of the idea is how can we
stack the chips in our favor so that it
would be unreasonable for us not to be
successful
if you only had to solve one problem for
one avatar and you only had one way that
you were going to approach them even if
you didn't know
how that channel worked even if you
weren't perfect to solve in the problem
since you only have to do those things
you will with enough iteration to solve
it and then the marketplace will reward
you what are you saying people need to
keep in mind when it gets to that one
million in take home which almost you
know no one gets to even the people that
are in freaking eight figure land
spending 700k a month on ads what's
what's important to keep in mind there
are what mistakes do people make when
not not making a profitable business the
lifetime gross profit per customer has
to be higher so to go from three to ten
you don't really need to change anything
besides making sure the customers are
more valuable you can do that by
improving the product and just like if
you have a recurring based business it's
reducing turn most the time and
optimizing pricing or adding a single
you know high value additional you know
service level right um and again you
might think well that's adding
operational complexity the answer is yes
it is adding operational complexity but
people who make 10 million are more
skilled than people who make three
million dollars and so that is a skill
that you need to acquire you know in the
path of getting there are there
exceptions absolutely but these are kind
of obviously broad-based for if i'm
talking specifically to high-ticket
coaches who are in a niche usually going
from three to ten million is going to
include increasing the lifetime value of
the customer in some way either by
introducing a back-end or keeping them
longer the other piece of it from what
you were saying earlier is that if you
have to spend that much money on
marketing it means the product's not
that good last question i have for you
alex because it's a big question why did
you write the book and what's your new
mission if it's not helping gyms be
super profitable yeah so right now we're
just helping businesses that are doing
about five million and up um get to you
know 30 50 million dollars a year
because now we've done it four times um
in the businesses that we own 100 of and
so now we're just doing it and
participating um in it so we just invest
in those companies we basically function
as
a makeshift exec team so we've got a cfo
cool there's me
vp sales and so all of those things
basically functioning because usually at
that five million dollar level the
issues you don't have enough talent not
enough experience and so we can just go
inject those in and then de-bottled like
all the things that we know because
we've done that so many times and so uh
in terms of the marketing perspective i
don't really have any desire to sell
masterminds coaches or courses because i
don't need to you know i mean the
businesses that we own already pump out
tons of cash flow and i just don't need
to do it nor do i really have the desire
and so the idea was i'll just make
basically my goal is to make the best
internet marketing business that exists
to make everything
and then if they're you know if someone
wants to get to that next level they've
already proven themselves uh
able to execute on the concepts that we
gave away for free then it means that
they're not gonna need handle holding
for me um which means that i've proven
that the information works because they
executed on it and they've proven to me
that they can do it um and so it's kind
of it works off of shared uh press right
off the bat and so that's that's kind of
the goal with the business and the real
real is that i think that when i die
nothing's going to happen and that
there's really no such thing as legacy
and if i have 100 generations people
forget who i am it makes me feel good
i love that i'm like giving you someone
up in one minute guys um please share
some love to alex uh alex thank you so
much he is the man that has nothing to
sell you plenty of people broken the
world he doesn't want you to be one of
them so make sure you check him out and
dive deeper into stuff alex appreciate
your friendship appreciate your input
this has been amazing have a great day
dude appreciate you guys thank you for
having me